I say to Congress I will never sign
another bill like this again I'm not
gonna do it again nobody read it it's
only hours old some people don't even
know what is it 1.3 trillion dollars
it's the second largest ever so why
didn't no one read it well I realize
that two thousand two hundred and thirty
two pages long that's all but that's all
the more reason to read the thing or do
normal course budgeting where it's bill
by Bill and you can actually digest it
one department at a time but Trump said
he signed the Omnibus because of a
desperate need to fund the military and
that he had no choice because of a
looming government shutdown but let's
face it it pains me to say this
the President did have a choice he could
have called Congress back to town and
made them pass a continuing resolution
until his priorities were funded and we
explained this mess to the American
people I tried in vain to warn him many
times this week an omnibus spending bill
is just what you have to know a
legislative scam it's a business as
usual spender Rama
at a time when voters expected just the
opposite from a president who campaigned
against the corrupt ik rats in DC as I
see it right now tonight the wall is
never going to happen because as we've
dug into this and really looked into
this this bill doesn't fund the wall at
all we can do better we must do better
or Republicans do not deserve to be in
the majority well voters elected
Republicans to both houses of Congress
and gave them the presidency to shrink
government spending and to shake up the
system not expand government and give in
to the system this is like Christmas for
Democrats I mean domestic spending goes
through the roof chuck schumer's like
like the cat who ate the canary
he gets his pet rail project Planned
Parenthood totally funded meanwhile
Trump gets a fraction of what he wanted
and
zero and I mean zero funding for that
big beautiful concrete border wall on my
radio show this morning in three hours
not a single caller and I wasn't trying
to weed out callers or make it all cute
here but not one wanted the President to
sign this legislation get that pen veto
that bill because it's pork it's a pork
laden built America's a family it isn't
an it is in debt that means saying no to
some fun stuff some good stuff even some
popular stuff so that we can actually
have a chance for survival President
Trump we are with you the American
people are with you but you need to be
with us fight for us president Trump I'm
voting for Donald Trump I was a strong
supporter of Trump should stop this sort
of thing and it just needs to be he's
got to take a stand now and stop this if
Trump doesn't veto this bill he's gonna
have to write a new book entitled the
art of the steel is this the president's
first serious breach with the base well
let's ask the only member of Congress
with a PhD in economics Republican from
the great Commonwealth of Virginia Dave
brat and Eric beech is the co-chair of
the pro Trump great America PAC and was
StuffIt amis is a Democratic strategist
great to have you all late at night on a
Friday was really important stuff let's
start with you congressman brat it broke
my heart and I was meaning you could ask
like my staff I was really down today I
mean I was I felt personally really
depressed I was in a funk because of
what happened and he got our hopes up
that he was gonna veto it this morning
but then you know the military guys was
like you gotta fund the military you're
gonna kill the military off and he ends
up signing it he said he wouldn't do it
again tell us how this went down well I
think you had it right it went down and
the hint to the American people as it
went down in the same way it's gone down
for the last ten years in a row and so
it's like Groundhog's Day whenever
you're running up to the date you know
it's going to be a disaster and that's
your big hint right why can't you
rationally plan the budget ahead
time you know you need nine votes in the
Senate right that's the huge obstacle we
did a budget the Senate wouldn't do a
budget the Democrats want increased
spending on everything so all that's a
given right so the president and
leadership need to go the American
people at the beginning of the cycle and
say okay we're going to give the
Democrats this this and this but we're
gonna hold strong on this and if you
shut down it's on the Democrats and so
we didn't go through that and then I'm
on the Budget Committee a month ago in
the when we did the budget this was the
spending bill but back in the budget the
Senate actually wrote a in the budget
that they will not do a budget for the
year coming up in 19 they don't even
want to do a budget because they don't
want to have a tough vote and so today
that made news Rush Limbaugh covered it
and Sean Hannity covered it and so
President Trump can go to the Senate
tomorrow and we can still get it right
in this year's budget if you don't do a
budget you don't get to do
reconciliation that's a big fancy word
but that's how we were gonna get rid of
Obamacare until the Senate tanked that
one and they owe us and that's how we
got tax okay yep okay so and we'll get
to it again we're gonna move this on but
when the president says I'll never do
this again I'll never vote for this
again could it be that he'll never get a
chance to vote on something like this
again congressman given what we know
happens in in the in the US Congress was
spending yeah well I hate to get
pessimistic but the base is dejected and
so he needs to come out and not only say
I won't do it again but take the
initiative and show him what he's going
to do in the next few months and force
it on the Senate and I yes you're right
that this may not happen again
because the Senate said we're not going
to do a budget this year
thank and then it got god help us if we
lose the house then it really won't
happen again right we're in a unique
opportunity right now to hit it out of
the park and we've got to do that in the
next month before November most stuff I
want to go to you because I was watching
Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi and all
these Democrats and I had some Democrats
on this week and they were in the best
mood they were like we're getting
Planned Parenthood we got timber they
thrilled and I said if I were you I
would be really happy to and I just said
I gotta hand it to you I never thought
this would happen but I gotta hand it to
you this is what Wolf Blitzer said after
the President signed the legislation
today let's watch he signs this Gloria
into law 2200 pages even though he says
no one has read it including himself
right which raises the question why sign
something into law that you haven't even
read well so he's not getting any credit
for it he signs it the Democrats like it
but wolf is right aren't no one's read
this legislation Rand Paul was tweeting
some of it last night but who knows if
he even read the 2,000 pages this is
crazy Mustafa for Democrats or
Republicans with and with it this is
generational theft of the next
generation your response a trillion
dollars in debt look what I liked about
the bill was the children's health
insurance has been funded for the next
ten years I think that's really
important and then you also saw 250
million dollars for democracy programs
in Russia and in sanctions in Russia so
I thought that got passed and and nobody
saw that I thought that was probably a
very good thing but I think Republican
voters have to ask themself they voted
for a Republican house a Republican
Senate and a Republican president and
they're still not getting what they want
so in this a 2018 election for the
midterms they should ask themselves
should they be voting for Republicans or
should they be avoiding for libertarians
or should there be you know sending a
message to Republicans and not voting at
all or avoiding for even Democrats I
mean that's what they republic goal
should be asking themselves Eric I want
to go to you on this because I I hear a
lot of spinning a lot of spinning oh
yeah the military needed a race we all
love the military but every time we end
up mortgaging our children's future all
we hear is well we need the military we
of course we need the military but
that's not an argument that's that's a
false that's false equivalency but
that's what we hear every time the
Republicans rolled this president there
is no border wall there's 33 miles of
like fixing the fence and some sensors
it is a travesty that they convinced him
early on that this was going to be a
real border wall and it was not well
they certainly lied to him but also I do
think the president was very heartfelt
when he talked about we need to make
sure that our military is not completed
and that was the sole reason why he
agreed to this omnibus bill and saying
that it's a trashy build
I'm caucus even discussed that and I
agree with Mustafa I think the great
irony here is you know there's four
leaders and the Republican - and the
Republican - and a Democrat side that
sat in the room and did a 2,000 page
build it didn't tell anybody about it
and the Republicans actually think they
can win elections I heard practitioners
talk today that the Republicans can win
elections but I agree with Democrat
Mustafa and what he said in terms of
this if you want to vote Republicans
into the house or the Senate to vote the
right kind of Republicans to ramp all
kind of Republicans because otherwise
you were gonna go down the same road
with the same parlor game and that's
what's undercutting the president at the
highest levels well but the president
could have come out today and said you
know something I've been I've been you
know pawing through this bill on page
734 look look at what it says well we
actually increased funding for a
department we said we were going to
decrease funding for we actually have
ridiculous projects to enforce other
countries borders while our borders will
still remain porous he could have done
that it would have been really bold and
it would have been I guess you know
sensational but congressman brat that's
how he won the election by defying the
establishment the conventional wisdom of
the media he looked right at them and
said I'm calling you on your
you-know-what and he could have done
that today brought them all back to
Washington and said start over because
you are perpetuating a fraud on the
American people